i'm just specific dude tell me all the
[ __ ] when i ask
you understand tell me all the [ __ ] when
i ask that's why i say when i order
tabasco and they say be right back and
they bring goddamn cholula
bring me shoes that's not that's not
bring me shoes if you're gonna bring me
cholula
congratulations dude that's not what i
wanted congratulations what if i did
that congratulations that's not what i
wanted congratulations they think i lost
my mind i can't wait to be 75 i'm going
to do [ __ ] like that
dude and and today actually i was at a
restaurant outside in the balcony
playing it safe
don't get mad and uh the lady comes by
and says
hey want any hot sauce and the way she
said it i was like yeah maybe i want
some hot sauce didn't really want some
hot sauce
but the way she said i was like you know
hustles might be nice and i said what
kind of hot sauce do you have
and she says this is what she says
cholula or sriracha cholula
what she says okay she goes like this
chalula chalular sriracha chalula
now she already
convinced me with her demeanor and her
energy
that i might want hot sauce don't
push it do not push it
do you understand it's disrespectful to
push it
it's nice to make a suggestion it's
disrespectful to push it
and hit me with the chalula
so i look right in her eyes and i say
nah
sriracha
dude and she goes like this oh all right
and she brought sriracha
and i didn't use it dude
you know how gangster that is i ain't
got
no [ __ ] why [ __ ] your [ __ ]
hell yeah dude want some hot sauce
hmm chris steps back and thinks for a
bit didn't really want hot sauce but the
way she said it made it seem inviting
sure i'll have hot sauce he says she
replies
cholula or sriracha and right as chris
is about to answer
she cuts him off chalula
chris steps back ponders
upset that she pushed it leans in
makes direct eye contact with her and
says
sriracha she
backs off on her heels a little bit and
insecurely says oh
all right time passes chris wonders
what's taking so long
he's a little bit mad but he's learning
to be a better person so he relaxes and
just eats the food without the hot sauce
she brings over some sriracha
and then chris doesn't use it
dude that's so gangster i'm the man for
that
i'm the man for that dude i can't wait
till calvin is old enough to understand
that story and i can tell him
yes dude i don't [ __ ] around man
this is real [ __ ] [ __ ] npr
this is real [ __ ] i want to do an npr
about sriracha
and [ __ ] tabasco or whatever the [ __ ]
i said tabasco's the number one by the
way
tabasco's the number one one time my
buddy i was in uh
i was in uh texas with my buddy and we
were in san antonio
and we went to some place or what would
the village
whatever that [ __ ] village in those
that that
southern chain or whatever it is i don't
remember what it's called something
village something
two times i went there one time was with
my ex-girlfriend when i was 19.
and she and and we were at this place it
was in utah
and the waiter said hey what do you guys
have and
and we all ordered and then she ordered
and whatever she ordered the waiter goes
like this
really and she says yeah
and i said what do you mean really is it
bad and he goes like this
nah it's just not what i would ordered
oh we do the balls on that waiter
[Music]
so now i'm in san antonio with my buddy
mitchell jones and
we're eating at this place forget what
it is but this guy
the waiter comes over and he says
what do you want for your side and i say
what do you have and he rambles off a
bunch of [ __ ] fries sweet potato fries
mashed potatoes whatever and then hits
me at the end with fried okra
now i being from california and new
jersey you have no idea
what fried okra is so i say what's fried
okra and he says
boiling never had no fried okra before
the most southern thing you can possibly
say in the world
dude it was unreal and i laughed like
hell
and we are friends even though we never
hung out we're friends that guy is my
sixth best friend because that's what he
did
and i [ __ ] love it yes dude i love
[ __ ] like that
and then there's the enemy coming up hey
you want sriracha about it
oh yeah cholula i'll look in your eyes
i'll say sriracha and you bring it i
won't eat it man
there's enemies and they're friends and
you know who they are
right when you meet them
you